- I've already taken cheeseburger,
and chicken burger, and French fries set,
and a bit of coke.
(pensive music)
Double cheeseburger.
Thanks, God, the same one, the same.
(people cheering)
- This new chain is replacing McDonald's,
which is one of the
most high-profile brands
to leave Russian after the
Russian invasion of Ukraine.
- [Sofiya] Here you can see the menu.
Okay, breakfast.
I think it's also the same.
(woman speaking in foreign language)
(Stepan speaking in foreign language)
(Oleg speaking in foreign language)
- Opening of the first McDonald's in 1990
was still when the Soviet Union
was intact was very symbolic.
It was seen as Russia's
opening to the West.
People enjoyed McDonald's.
There was something
that they could count on
on long road trips.
They knew what the quality is going to be.
They knew it's going to be clean,
the standards are there.
And they could count on
what they were going to eat.
- Every member in my family
has a favorite food set.
My mum loves Caesar roll,
my grandma likes potato wedges.
And I can say that I'm really
big fan of the old McDonald's.
(pensive music)
- Politicians in Russia
are positioning this reopening
as a way to show that Russia can do well
despite all the sanctions and
the boycotts by corporations.
It's kind of an easy case
that won't prove much.
Sure, they will be able to make burgers
but will they be able to make cars?
Will they be able to make airplanes?
(pensive music)
(voices murmuring)
(server speaking in foreign language)
- What happens next is unclear.
McDonald's hasn't commented on that.
McDonald's can bid on the
franchise again in the future.
We don't know whether it does so
and under what circumstances.